can I keep my own accent okay like I
like it
founder we all go a little mad sometimes
a little mad sometimes
hey check this out
I found the ass end so I feel like
someone's been severed and they found
that yeah yeah it's gotta be something
that's funny
it's gotta be I don't know yeah tremors
[Music]
I found me a pen
don't [ __ ] with Chuck with Dutch Chuck
oh not like saw or someone's like Chucky
Oh cosplay Chucky Chucky dolls play
three [ __ ] with the Chuck what do you
want to see what your insides look like
oh I think I know that scream to see
what your side
by the way I would have voted for Obama
for a third term if I could get out best
president in my lifetime hands down very
good I thought you were just saying by
the way I would have voted for Obama for
a third term if I could best president
my lifetime hands down I'm a TS
[ __ ] a we handle [ __ ] that's
what we do consider this situation
[ __ ] handled Oh get out very high
rating on Rotten Tomatoes I'm TS
[ __ ] a we handle [ __ ] that's
what we do consider this situation
[ __ ] a handle I'm your number one fan
yes the fan misery six years up to this
moment darling night of my life I'm not
gonna hurt you you didn't let me finish
my sentence I said I'm not gonna hurt
you I'm just gonna bash your brains in
whoa Oh
but they've got the back give me back
the back oh we all suck except I got all
those other ones right so darling light
of my life I'm not gonna hurt you
you didn't let me finish my sentence I
said I'm not gonna hurt you
I'm just gonna bash your brains what I
did I killed a vet I hated it so much it
it it flames what I play all of that I
killed a vet man okay
Oh Yvette okay breathing breathless
keeping breaths keeping Oh killed event
clueless clue
so much it the flame flames flames on
the side of my face oh you got a letter
I got ran over Helen gets her hair
chopped off and Julie gets a body in her
trunk and you get a letter that's
balanced I could have done that better
okay
I know what you did last summer whoa oh
you got a letter I got run over Helen
gets her hair chopped off Julie gets a
body in a trunk and you get a letter
that's balanced okay I didn't want to
say it well I would have a view didn't
and we're to get married
[Music]